It started to pace towards my bed.
I could not even describe to you the motion
it used to walk.
Hello, and welcome to Al Dente Sleepypasta,
horror stories dreamed to perfection with
a wave of nightmares and terror.
My name is CZ, and I will be your somnambulist
this episode.
I'll also be joined by The Dark Somnium.
Dreams are a lot like death.
We know how and when they happen, but we'll
never fully understand them.
This time we'll be exploring a few creepy
accounts of dreams, or more accurately, nightmares.
Let’s tuck right in.
Number One.
Wakeup Syndrome.
Do you ever wake up in a hotel, or at a friend's
house, and for those first few seconds of
consciousness, not know exactly where you
are?
Like it takes a few moments for you to realize
you aren't in your own bed; that you've gone
on vacation, or that you've passed out in
a buddy's guest room?
This always used to happen to me when I would
go away to summer camp as a kid.
It would happen during the first week or so.
I would wake up, thinking I was in my own
bed… at least until I opened my eyes and
came to the realization that I was in a cabin,
miles away from home.
That same thing would always happen to me
during those first couple days home from camp.
I would pop out of bed ready to go for a hike
or a kayak, only to discover that my mind
had been playing tricks on me again.
I don’t know if there is a proper term for
this phenomenon, but I’m sure that anyone
who has traveled before probably knows what
I’m talking about.
When I first started university, I used to
get that feeling all of the time.
I'd imagine I was back at home in high school.
Back then, if I slept in too late, Mom would
send my sister Tara in to wake me up.
Tara was always the early riser between the
two of us.
On weekends, you could count on her being
up before 9:00 every day.
I was always more of a night owl and preferred
to stay up late watching movies, then sleep
in to around noon or something.
But during the school week, as you can imagine,
no such snoozing was allowed, and Tara would
be sent in to wake me up.
Tara: “Naaattthhhaaannn!
Nathan, wake up!
You're gonna miss the bus!
Come on you sleepyhead!”
Sometimes she would even bring our dog, Myuu,
in to help her out.
Tara: "Go get him Myuu!"
At 15-20 pounds, Myuu was hardly a force to
be taken seriously.
But what made him such an effective alarm
clock was his constant burning desire for
attention.
He would jump all the way up on my bed, run
on top of my weary body and lick my face until
finally, I mustered up the stamina to wake
up and go get ready for school.
Tara: "That a boy Myuu!
Good job buddy".
When I moved away to attend school, I quickly
learned I’d have to set my own alarm clocks
if I wanted to make it to class on time.
The human mind really is an amazing thing,
for better or for worse.
Every week or so during my first term, I would
wake up in my dorm thinking I was still back
home in my old bed again.
I would even hear Tara's words echo in my
head before I could peel my eyes open.
Tara: "Naaattthhhann!
Wake up dude.
The bus is going to be here!"
Eventually, it stopped happening.
At least for the most part.
I guess my mind just grew accustomed to the
fact that I’d be staying in the dorms from
now on.
But every now and then, it still happens.
I’m a sophomore now and last week, I’d
visited home for Spring Break.
I got back to school late last night and immediately
hit the sack before meeting up with any of
my friends.
Sure enough, this morning, I awoke with that
same old feeling.
As I slowly started to wake up, my eyes remained
closed as I tried to doze back off to sleep.
In my mind, I was home.
I even heard my sister’s words echoing through
my head, just like old times.
Tara: "Naaattthhhann!
Wake up!
Do you want to make us late?"
I groaned, and rolled over, trying to ignore
the world around me for just a little while
longer.
But as I started to come to, I soon realized
it was all in my head, and I was back at university
again, Tara was not here and I could sleep
in to my heart’s content.
But then it happened.
Once I realized where I was, I started to
fall back to sleep.
And for a short while, I was relaxed.
THAT'S WHEN I FELT MYUU LICK MY FACE.
[growling sound effect]
Number Two.
CreepsMcPasta narrated my nightmare.
[alarm sound effect]
I recently began listening to creepypasta
narrations each night before bed.
Now I know for some people, that is probably
a terrible idea, that would likely result
in a state of fear; not being able to sleep
or being riddled with terrible nightmares.
I even have friends that won't watch a horror
movie past 9PM, for fear that they will not
be able to sleep that night if they do.
I, however, am not like most people.
I've been mostly desensitized to such movies,
so finding a story that really scares me is
an exciting occurrence.
I welcome any nightmares that may arise.
As you get older, it becomes very difficult
to find anything that scares you like when
you were a child.
Sure there are worries and stresses that come
with adulthood, but real terror becomes a
real rarity by the time you hit 8th grade,
other than in your dreams.
So I started pulling up a creepypasta on YouTube
each night before bed and letting it play
as I closed my eyes, visualized the story
in my head, and hoped that if I was lucky,
maybe I'd get the thrill of a nightmare racksacking
my thoughts that evening.
At least, that's what I thought I wanted...
until recently, when I had a nightmare so
terrifying, I've had to rethink my outlook
entirely.
See, the strange thing about the horror narrators
on YouTube, is that while their voices can
be creepy and unsettling, they also have to
be aesthetically pleasing to the listeners'
ears, so they also tend to have the most soothing,
full-sounding voices out of anyone you might
hear.
And what I've come to find is that oftentimes
the result, is like that of a lullaby and
after listening to a couple of stories, their
voices can ease you right to sleep.
That's another reason I had continued to listen
to stories before bed.
Some of my favorite narrators were The Dark
Somnium, Lady White Rabbit, Mortis Media and
CreepsMcPasta.
Creeps was usually my go-to for falling asleep,
as he has that relaxing tone of voice that
just puts you at ease and makes it easy to
drift off while listening to some classic
internet horror stories.
He also uploads nearly every day, so there's
usually a new video to listen to each night,
which is nice.
Every now and then, Creeps will upload something
known as a compilation video, which consists
of all of his narrations from that month,
combined into one long video, which tends
to land around 4 hours or so.
I had fallen asleep listening to one of these
compilation videos when I discovered what
I'll call... an intriguing life hack.
I found that listening to a long enough story
at just the right volume can result in me
actually hearing the creepypasta narration
in my dreams!
This was obviously insanely cool for me, but
it didn't stop there.
What I discovered, was that my dreams would
actually change based on what I was hearing
in the story.
Have you ever had someone touch you or kick
you while you were asleep, and have something
similar happen in your dream as result?
I imagine that it's the same concept here,
only instead of a physical response, my brain
was responding to the audio.
Needless to say, I had a lot of fun experimenting
with this trick, forcing myself to have dreams
of classic horror stories, creating playlists
for myself so I can control which stories
play when I enter my REM sleep cycle and getting
myself genuinely horrified when the stories
took a turn for the worst.
At first, if there was any kind of loud noise
or music change in the narrative [stinger]
it would jolt me awake, but the more I listened,
the more I became desensitized to it.
After a couple of months I was able to sleep
through any music or sound effects and Creeps
was the soundtrack to my nightmares.
I worked my way through the essentials, until
I got to Teeth.jpg...
I had set it up so that the story would start
after 90 minutes.
So basically, when my dream picked up, the
story has just started.
Teeth.jpg, if you’re not familiar with it,
is about four art students who live together
and come back from one summer break to one
of the roommates undergoing a strange and
disturbing behaviour change.
What made this experience so real for me,
was that when you are in a dream, you don’t
really question what’s going on for whatever
reason.
So although the characters in this creepypasta,
Josh, Lily, and Daniel, the psycho one, are
completely fictional, I felt like they were
my closest friends during the dream.
My mind never really tried to challenge the
fact that I just lived in this world with
these characters.
In one of the early scenes, Daniel goes missing
late at night and I, as the main character
of this story, end up finding the creepy teeth.jpg
file on his computer.
"I noticed that he had a USB plugged in and
two files on screen.
One was called 'dentist photos', and the other
file was a singular image named teeth.jpg.""
In the dream, when I am going through his
files, I keep on looking over the door, and
despite the fact that I know this story in
real life, it’s like I don’t know what’s
going to happen in the moment, so I feel like
Daniel is going to come walking in any second.
The strange thing was, every time I looked
back at the door, it was different.
The lighting outside would change, and the
angle at which the door was open was always
different.
I would see shadows on the wall sometimes,
despite the fact that nobody was really there.
That was tripping me out, but in addition
to that, there were a bunch of files on Daniel’s
computer other than those mentioned in the
story, and I looked at them, despite the fact
that Creeps’ narration did not instruct
me to do so.
They were photos.
Real photos from my Facebook page.
Most of which were ones that I was in.
Me and my friends.
Me and my girlfriend.
Me and my ex-girlfriend.
And again, at the time, I didn’t realize
I was dreaming, I was just taking this all
at face, and it was really freaking me out.
I ran out of the room and hit my foot on the
doorframe on the way out.
It really hurt.
It wasn’t like a dream at all.
The pain was so realistic and it was pulsing
through my leg.
There were more strange deviations that occurred
in this dream.
For example, when we suspected Daniel of doing
something to Lily and went through his bag.
"I picked up the satchel and emptied it's
contents onto the coffee table."
I immediately recognized the items that poured
out of my bag.
The were all the same objects that I have
sitting on my nightstand: the alarm clock,
my phone, a box of tissue and a picture frame.
I reached out to pick up my alarm clock, but
when my hand got to the point of touching
it, I couldn’t feel anything.
I couldn’t pick it up.
Since this was a dream, I didn’t find this
that out of the ordinary.
It just felt more like I was doing something
wrong, as opposed to some kind of glitch in
reality.
There were also some photographs of Lily.
"We noticed on the back of the photographs,
there were labels and each tooth on each photo
was marked.
There were notes on the photos that said things
like, 'remove' or 'replace'."
I found that these were much easier for me
to interact with and I was able to pick up
each one and inspect the markings.
They were polaroid photos, which doesn’t
really make sense thinking back on it, but
each one had Lily’s teeth notated with permanent
marker.
We began searching for Lily, and it felt like
we were wandering around aimlessly forever.
Days even.
It’s strange how time can seem to be uncompressed
when you’re dreaming.
Eventually we found the house.
Josh kicked down the door and we explored
onward into the basement.
Upon entering, I was met with a foul odor
that instantly sickened me.
Typically smell has usually been a non-factor
for me in dreams, but this, just like when
I banged my foot, was so real.
I didn’t want to be there anymore.
I couldn’t stand to go on.
But I was fighting the movement of my own
body!
It was obeying each of Creeps’ commands,
which were booming over us in his calm, familiar
voice and echoing all throughout the basement.
I wasn’t in control anymore but I could
still feel the wretched nausea caused by that
smell.
I wanted to go outside and throw up but I
couldn’t do that.
I was continuing on against my own will.
I looked at Josh and he actually seemed to
be unaffected by it, and it was at that point
where I think I gradually started to realize
that I was in a dream.
No… a nightmare, I could not wake up from.
We found Lily’s sweater.
At this point I actually did throw up.
I’ll avoid the grotesque details of what
happened next as much as possible.
But I have to get my point across.
Through my own eyes I could see the puke piling
up on the floor.
But how I felt was much different than that.
It was like it was piling up and wouldn’t
leave my mouth.
I started spitting, choking, doing whatever
I could to prevent myself from drowning in
my own waste.
But the grossness of all of this was making
me sicker and making it clog my mouth even
more.
I felt like I was going to suffocate, and
then somehow I was able to clear my airways.
I’m not really sure how.
Sorry about that.
No more gross parts.
We wandered around around in the dark.
Someone turned on a red light.
I heard Josh scream.
It was probably the loudest thing I had ever
heard.
It was so loud that it temporarily overtook
the sound of CreepsMcPasta’s narrations.
It echoed everywhere in the room, piercing
my eardrums.
It felt like my head might pop, but then the
echoes slowly faded out.
That’s when I saw Lily.
Eyes gouged.
Teeth repurposed.
At this point I knew I was in a nightmare.
And I wanted out.
I tried sitting up.
Opening my eyes.
None of that worked.
I heard the footsteps come up behind me.
I pinched myself.
Nothing.
"I’m sorry you had to find out this way.
But it’s OK.
It’s all for the sake of art."
Daniel’s dialogue was perfectly in sync
with the booming narration.
I beat my fist against my body.
No luck.
I started punching myself in the face.
NO MATTER WHAT I DID…
I couldn’t.
Wake.
Myself.
Up.
That’s when I was yanked backwards into
the dark.
My stomach dropped as this happened and my
eyes were blurry and filled with tears.
I kicked.
I fought.
But I couldn’t make contact.
Daniel was was beating and bludgeoning my
with what must have been a somewhat sharp
metal post.
All the pain was real.
It was an intense searing pain.
It was unlike anything I had felt, in waking
or in sleep.
I was bleeding.
I could tell because I reached to grasp my
injury and it felt wet.
And then suddenly, it just stopped, as Creeps
gave the final narration.
"I could hear Lily... choking..."
I thought I was done for, but then everything
around me, the entire environment, just faded
away.
I found myself laying in a white void.
I guess it's true what they say.
How you can't die in your dream.
I've just been laying here for... what feels
like days, but realistically has been about
9 hours and 15 minutes.
How do I know this?
[alarm sound effect]
My alarm just went off for the second time,
and it isn't waking me up.
I’m starting to doubt it ever will.
Number 3.
This Strange Man Is In All My Dreams.
I'm sitting in an airport right now.
My flight is delayed so I'm going to do my
best to write this story before it's time
to board the flight.
Have you ever dreamed of a character, who
seems to only exist in your dreams?
Most of the characters in my dreams are people
that I know I'm real life.
Occasionally I'll dream of a character from
a TV show, or celebrity crush, but the point
is they are all people that I can picture
in my head.
Sure, there may be one that I made up from
time to time, but if that does happen they
are usually only going to appear in one dream.
Except for this one guy.
For the last few years this guy has been in
almost every one of my dreams; at least the
ones that I can remember.
As far as I know he's never had a name.
He's bald, probably in his 60's or something
though I suck at guessing people's ages.
He has a thin mustache and wrinkles his eyes.
Yellow teeth.
Not real straight.
I wouldn't call him overweight but he's definitely
not in shape.
The strange thing is: this is the first time
I've been able to clearly remember what he
looks like outside of my dream.
But I'll get back to that in a minute.
So usually this man just shows up in random
situations in my dream.
Like he might be delivering me this package,
or if I'm having a test dream he'll be the
teacher.
If I'm being chased in my dream, he is usually
the malevolent pursuer.
If it's a getting walked-in-on dream, he tends
to be the one to catch me.
So he always plays that kind of role.
I don't think I've ever held a conversation
with him in any of these.
I can’t really remember him talking at all
to be honest.
So that brings me to today.
I am flying out to Denver for work and the
flight gets delayed because of inclement weather.
It’s early in the morning and I’m tired,
so I decided to nod off for a little bit in
the airport.
Now I can never remember the beginning of
my dreams but, the first thing I remember
was watching my son play Jak and Daxter.
Quick backstory on that, my kid was really
into The Last of Us, so recently I dug out
my old PS2 and introduced him to the Jak and
Daxter series because they're made by the
same studio and he really took a liking to
it.
I don’t know if other people have this happen
in their dreams, but I have a lot of dreams
where I’ll be watching a movie or playing
a game, and I kind of gradually become one
of the characters.
I’m assuming I’m not the only one who
gets that.
So I’m in this game and I’m exploring
this area called Misty Island.
I think I was supposed to be finding this
power cell or something, I don’t remember
the exact details of the objective.
But me and my son were both inside of this
game.
He kept running ahead to explore, and I would
try to keep close to him, because as the name
of the island suggests, it was very hazy and
I was afraid he was going to be lost or something
was going to happen to him.
The problem is, I kept slipping on the gravel
underneath my feet, and it was becoming a
challenge to even stay upright.
He was just kind of running around carelessly
and I lost him for a minute as he ran around
this cliff.
I sprinted to catch up with him.
When I came around the cliff, there was nothing
there.
I was not only worried about my son getting
lost, but also the threat of Lurkers, which
if you aren’t familiar with the game, are
these creepy purple reptilian creatures with
yellow eyes.
Almost on cue, one of these creatures crawled
out of the cliffside and crossed right in
front of me, stopping me in my tracks.
It continued on towards the shore and disappeared
in the fog.
Then I noticed someone standing far in the
distance shrouded in fog.
I called out my son’s name, but he didn’t
respond.
He was just standing still staring out at
the water.
I began to run up towards him, when a Lurker
bounded out from the trees, jumped, and struck
him in the head before scampering off!
My heart sank in my chest and I sprinted with
everything I had.
When I reached him I discovered, it was not
my son, but rather…
No… it couldn’t be…
What I saw lying there on the sand, was the
man from my dreams, only in video game polygon
form.
Somehow, his appearance was even creepier
in compressed textures and PS2 graphics, yet
the injury to his head was terrifyingly realistic.
His body then compressed into green eco in
the typical fashion of the game’s death
animation, and he was gone.
I progressed to the area that is essentially
the end of the level and where I saw my son
standing up on a platform, waiting for me.
As I got closer, I noticed there was someone
else standing there as well, and sure enough,
it was the man, again…
He had his hand on my son’s shoulder and
they were both just staring at me.
Not knowing what to do, I froze in my tracks.
Before I could come to a decision…
I was jolted out of the game, and I was back
in my son’s room, staring at a blank screen.
I looked over to the chair my son had been
sitting in.
What I saw was the chord from his controller
stretched across the chair, like he had gotten
up and was standing as far back as the cable
length would allow him.
I followed the stretch of cable with my eyes
to meet my son’s gaze… but was instead
met with…
An adult pair of hands dropped the plastic
controller to the floor.
It was him.
He was just grinning at me with the most insane
stare.
I was startled, nearly falling back out of
my chair.
My first instinct was to swing my feet around
and stumble out of the room.
I ran down the hall.
The house seemed to be empty, but strangely,
all of the doors to every room were open.
I looked over my shoulder as I turned the
corner.
He had grown to about 9 feet tall and his
eyes were deadlocked on me as he ducked under
the doorframe exiting my son’s room and
began to make his way in my direction.
I went for the front door.
In typical nightmare fashion, it was locked,
but for whatever reason I didn’t think to
just reach down and unlock it.
I fiddled with the doorknob anxiously as I
looked over my shoulder and saw the man walking
around the corner and coming for me with that
creepy grin on his face.
The doorknob fell to the ground.
The thing had broken off or something.
As a last ditch effort I reared back and just
kicked the door in.
What happened next, is sort of difficult to
put into words.
I was in the car, just driving as fast as
I could, within reason.
It was a lot like the phenomenon I explained
earlier, where at first I was watching the
video game and then we were gradually in it.
In this case, I started off alone in the car,
but at some point, I realized I was in the
car with that guy.
I know it doesn't make sense, but in the context
of the dream I didn’t question it.
He wasn’t making any moves or anything.
Literally, he was just sitting there with
his stupid grin.
But as time went on, I was just getting more
nervous that he was about to do something.
I kept looking over at him.
Looking back at the road.
Then back at him.
I was trying to keep my eye on him and make
sure he wasn’t going anywhere.
Him.
The road.
The next time I looked back at him, he was
breathing more and more heavily.
I was getting nervous.
My palms were sweating.
I looked back at the road to find I had run
out of road!
I was about to drive over the edge into the
water!
I slammed the brakes, but it was too late,
I broke through the barrier and propelled
off the edge!
A shiver went up my spine as I was startled
awake.
To my relief, it was all just a crazy dream.
Just as I woke up, a woman in a purple dress
swiftly crossed in front of me.
My gaze followed her to the window.
It was almost white with fog.
It seemed that there would still be a significant
delay until we could take off.
Just then I dropped my bottle of water.
I had purchased before heading to my gate
and forgotten that I’d fallen asleep with
it in my hand.
I reached down to grab and as I came back
up, I saw something that frightened and disturbed
me…
The man from my dreams.
He was sitting in the seat across from me.
Just grinning at me.
Number 4.
My Sleep Paralysis Amplified
I started my new job a few days ago.
Well, to be entirely accurate, it’s not
a new job, I just got transferred to another
branch.
In a another timezone.
My doctor says that the stress of having a
new job, new schedule and new life are all
probably contributing to my severe sleep issues
and hallucinations I’ve been having.
OK, maybe I’m getting ahead of myself here.
Let me take a step back.
My name is Alex.
I’m 28 years old and single.
I work for a pretty sizable company that sells
consumer and professional grade amplifiers
to musicians.
I’m the guy who makes sure you actually
get the thing you ordered and get it on time.
It was recently decided that it would be a
good idea for people like me, to be close
to the people who are selling these products.
Why they didn’t realize that in the first
place?
Beyond me.
But recently I found myself packing up and
moving across the country.
So I was kind of annoyed about the whole relocation
thing for my first 10 minutes at the new office.
I was supposed to be meeting some of these
sales people who I would now be working alongside.
Enter Caitlyn.
Luminescent light brown eyes.
Short, but not too short, brunette hair.
Dimples.
To.
Die for.
I quickly got over any annoyance I had with
having to move and started to think I was
going to like this new office.
By the end of the first day, Caitlyn and I
already had at least three inside jokes.
“See, I told you the copy machine outsmarted
Lenny!”
I told her as I headed out for the day.
Don’t worry, you’re not supposed to get
it.
It’s one of our inside jokes.
She laughed and told me she’d see me tomorrow.
She has such a cute laugh.
Sorry, I got distracted there for a second.
At the end of the day, I was exhausted.
Famished.
I was so eager to retire to bed.
But when I layed down and shut my eyes…
I just couldn’t fall asleep.
I kept opening my eyes and looking at the
clock.
One o’clock.
Two o’clock.
Two thirty.
Why wasn’t I falling asleep?
Was it this new bed?
Was it this new apartment?
I looked around my new pad and thought about
how funny it was that I still always close
bedroom door, despite being the only one here
now.
Old habits do die hard I suppose.
Maybe I couldn’t sleep because I was thinking
too much?
Maybe Caitlyn was on my mind too.
Eventually at some point I must have dozed
off.
But when I awoke.
It was still dark out.
Out of the corner of my eye I saw the clock.
Four twenty-three in the morning.
Ugh.
I was feeling pretty thirsty so I hopped up
to grab some water…
only…
when I hopped up to grab some water, my body
didn’t move an inch.
Come to think of it, I hadn’t moved at all
since I had woken up.
I immediately felt a wave of terror crash
over me.
What was going on?
Why can’t I move?
What’s wrong with me?
I was instantly overcome with anxiety and
discomfort.
It was like a nightmare.
Where nothing happens.
But it was a nightmare because nothing was
happening.
What if I was stuck like this forever?
Who will think to come check on me?
What if I starve to death like this?
What if…
What if…?!
[alarm sound effect]
The next thing I remember was me waking up
the next morning.
To my relief, I was able to get up and hit
the alarm clock now.
What was that last night?
Some kind of weird dream?
Or was it real?
It felt real… but it doesn’t seem real.
I brought my own lunch to work that day.
I opened up the fridge to find…
it’s completely stuffed.
I couldn’t find an open spot anywhere, so
I start to rearrange stuff to make room.
“What are you doing?”
I hear from behind me.
I turn to see this guy Jerry standing there.
Jerry is the head of the sales department.
Every office has that guy, right?
From what I could tell so far in my one day
here, Jerry is the guy who makes you want
to take the stairs when you see him waiting
for the elevator.
And I might be speaking from experience already.
“I was just--”
“Why do you have my food in your hand?”,
he asked in the most accusatory manner I’ve
ever heard in my life.
He snatched the bag from me.
“I was just trying to make space, so that
I could fit my lunch.”
“Yeah.
OK.”
He walked away.
Hey, no complaint from me.
Now I had a spot to put my lunch in!
Throughout the day, I made sure to visit Caitlyn
and make sure she wasn’t “overworking”
herself.
Sometimes people forget to take little breaks.
I was just looking out for my fellow employee.
The lack of sleep the night before had me
all worn out.
I was positive that this time, I would have
no trouble whatsoever with passing out.
I shut my bedroom door behind me and literally
collapsed on my bed.
I continued to lie awake for a while though.
I looked at my clock periodically. 11:17.
12:03.
12:15.
12:17.
I was growing restless.
I guess at some point though, I knocked out,
because a couple of hours later, I woke up
in the middle of the night again.
Great…
I tried to look at the clock, but I couldn’t
see it from the position I was in.
That’s when I realized…
It had happened again.
I couldn’t move.
Once again I was overcome with fear.
Was this going to become a regular thing?
However, what I saw next was about to take
my fear and amplify it.
My door was open, and this creature was standing
in the doorway.
It was humanoid, but it’s body was all pitch
black and it was probably 7 or 8 feet tall.
It’s head was shaped like the top of a tree
stump that had been struck by lightning and
it’s eyes were glowing red.
It’s mouth opening resembled a polygon with
completely random angles.
But the scariest part to me, for whatever
reason, was it’s fingers.
Each one was long and branch-like.
Probably about 2ft in length.
They were just dangling there and he…
well…
it was moving them around in a wave motion.
I tried to move.
I tried to scream!
But what I found is that I could not even
do that.
It started to pace towards my bed.
I
could not even describe to you the motion
it used to walk.
It reached the foot the bed.
I was fighting with every ounce of energy
I had, but my body would not budge.
It came along the side of the bed and continued
to inch closer to me.
I tried to scream for help, and just managed
to get out the slightest sound.
“H-help.
Help!”
[Alarm sound effect]
“HELP!”
I screamed out as I sat up.
It was morning.
Again I was left with the mystery of what
this sleep paralysis was.
I decided it was time to see a doctor about
it and made an appointment for after work.
I wasn't going to let my rough night ruin
my perfect day, however.
Today, I had a plan.
When I got to work, Jerry was waiting for
the elevator.
I smoothly redirected myself towards the stairs,
I could almost feel him sneering at me back.
By the time I made it up the stairs, Jerry
was talking to Caitlyn about something.
Luckily I saw him walk away as I walked up.
I stopped and said hello to Caitlyn.
She flashed her infectious smile at me.
Sure, I was tired, but things were going well.
I didn't bring my lunch to work today.
Instead, when it got to my break time, I went
over to Caitlin's desk and invited her to
go grab some food with me.
She delightfully accepted.
We got sandwiches.
And we totally hit it off.
We were talking and cracking jokes the entire
time.
She does this little thing where she'll get
excited about something and kind of bite her
lip.
It's incredible.
We got back to the office and she offered
me a mint from her drawer.
I accepted, so she went to open the little
box of mints and accidentally spilled a bunch
of them on her desk.
We both reached for the loose mints.
I saw my chance and grabbed her hand and held
it in mine.
“Here relax, I'll take care of this.”
I told her, and used my other hand to gather
the mints.
“What's going on here?”
I heard the stern voice that belonged to Jerry
as he walked up.
She quickly pulled her hands away.
I finished gathering up the mints and after
taking one for myself, deposited the rest
back in the container.
I was taken aback by what she said next…
She told him… hey babe, we just got back
from lunch.
My heart sank deep into my chest and my head
started burning up.
Did my ears deceive me?
Did she really just call Jerry, the prick
of the office and her boss, “babe”?
Surely this must be a joke; a cruel meme of
some kind.
He came up behind her and kissed the top of
her head, crushing whatever hope I had left
and glaring at me as he did so.
I couldn't believe it.
How is this idiot better than me?
I felt myself starting to blush.
I felt so stupid thinking she was into me.
She was just being friendly.
How did I not see this coming?
“Uhh…
I gotta get back to work.”
She thanked me for my company at lunch.
As I turned away I could feel his glare on
me so strongly that I wished I’d worn sunscreen.
“You went out to lunch with that guy?”
I heard him ask her, with an attitude as I
fled the scene.
Great.
Three days and I was already making enemies.
The rest of my afternoon was so hard to get
through.
I was constantly dozing off at my desk.
Not enough to fully fall asleep, mind you.
Just enough to feel as about as miserable
as I felt rejected.
I wanted to just go home and sleep, but I
had my doctor's appointment that evening.
The doc confirmed what I pretty much already
knew.
I had sleep paralysis.
One and every 12 people get it or something.
He questioned me about my lifestyle and when
he found out I had just made a big move, he
was almost positive that was the reason for
my issues.
Psychological stress and abnormal sleep cycles
are apparently the two biggest factors that
usually contribute to it.
He told me that the hallucinations are a common
symptom, basically my body thinks it’s asleep
while it’s awake.
I was supposed to see a psychiatrist if the
problem persisted once I’d settled into
my new routine.
Not exactly the treatment I was hoping for,
but it was somewhat reassuring that he expected
me to recover on my own.
That night I actually had a better time falling
asleep than before.
I must have been out by 11 or 12.
But that didn’t stop me from waking up in
the middle of the night again, unable to move,
unable to speak.
Officially knowing that I suffered from sleep
paralysis didn’t make the experience any
less scary.
When you have it, it feels like you’re never
going to wake up from it.
And the things you see feel incredibly real,
and you feel incredibly helpless.
That’s why I wanted to scream when I saw
a knife-wielding silhouette standing in my
doorframe.
The man stepped forward and caught a little
bit of moonlight, just enough for me to identify
who it was.
Jerry.
As per usual, he did NOT look happy to see
me.
He tip-toed across the room to the foot of
my bed and stared down at me with disgust.
He continued to look at me for about 2 full
minutes.
His body was trembling.
Finally, he came around to the side of the
bed, taking an almost identical path to the
creature from the night before.
He raised the knife in the air, gripping it
so hard that I could see the loss of circulation
to his fingers.
He froze in that position, almost like he
was waiting for me to make the first move.
I couldn’t take it!
The anxiety was killing me!
I just wanted him to do it already to get
it over with!
The last thing I could remember though, was
him, stuck in that position, trembling like
a maniac.
Morning came.
I turned off my alarm clock and the post-nightmare
relief felt incredible as it dawned on me.
I actually felt pretty decent for once.
Not back to where I was before the move, but
not 100% exhausted either.
It was Friday so I thought maybe I’d have
the energy to go out on the town and explore
my new city after work tonight.
Maybe it would help get my mind off things.
I hopped out of bed and as I began to get
dressed…
I realized something.
Something that flushed whatever optimism or
relief I had away.
Something that made my body and legs lock
up, just as they had the two previous nights.
Something that made my heart sink deep into
my chest, just as it had when I found out
about Caitlyn and Jerry.
What I realized was… my bedroom door was
open...
Thanks for snoozing in with us in Al Dente
Sleepypasta.
I did this collab with The Dark Somnium.
He is a massively underrated horror narrator.
If you like Al Dente Creepypasta, if you appreciate
the original music, the cinematic sound design,
the quality graphic design, you should seriously
consider going over to subscribe to his channel.
He is all about that stuff and always does
great work.
When I started Al Dente Creepypasta in October,
I wanted to fill a void where I saw room for
improvement in the genre, and hopefully inspire
some others to go the extra distance as well.
So it’s great to see The Dark Somnium pulling
off these high standards of quality and I’d
love to see him get recognition for it as
well.
While I was making this video I actually fell
asleep and had this nightmare where we were
doing the Deadstream, the on-the-air horror
podcast that I do with Lady White Rabbit and
Mortis Media, and everything just kept going
wrong.
I couldn’t get the animations to play correctly
and there was all this background noise and
interruptions.
I guess these are the kinds of things that
YouTubers have nightmares about.
The other thing we have nightmares about is
you, the viewers, not getting notified about
our uploads, so please make sure you’re
subscribed and make sure that your deathbell
notifications are on.
Subscribing honestly does nothing unless you
click that little bell next to the subscribe
button.
I don’t know why it’s like that now, but
you have to take that extra step.
Otherwise you’ll be missing out on new horrors
every week.
I’ll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.